Toys R Us is a story that most of us
have gone to in our early childhood to
shop for the newest level sets or go
holiday shopping it truly is a shame
that they were forced to file for
bankruptcy just last year I was there
once the market leaders recently however
there has been news of Toys R Us trying
to come back under a new brand name so
why did Toys R Us fail in the first
place and can they come back make sure
to grow until the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to hurry salaries so all stored
when Charles Lazarus came back from
World War two I'm selling down in 1948
World War two had just ended and Lazarus
noticed that people are coming back
settling down and having kids he had a
hunch that there's going to be a lot
more demand for baby related items so
you found a baby furniture retailer in
children supermarket in Washington DC in
1948 he had a lot of requests for baby
toys and once he added baby toys he got
a lot of requests to add children's toys
and when he added that he kept getting
more requests for more and more toys as
a result he opened the first toys RS
which is dedicated at toys and not
furniture in Rockville Maryland he
designed the logo himself and put the
are backwards an effort to make it look
like a kid rotate this was the first big
box toy store most toys her son told now
were small family-run stores they would
have display cases and decorative
interiors but Toys R Us had a concrete
or tile floors and toys arrests had rows
of toys laid out next each other more
like a grocery store than a toy store
throughout the 60s and 70s yes some of
the most iconic toys of all time like
mr. Potato Head and Barbie and Lazarus
had a huge adventure with competition as
here to buy such a high volume of Unix
and as a result he did it for a lot
cheaper than his competitors retail
historians described this as the first
category killer a business that are so
dominating that crafts off all our
competition TV is heavily assisted this
rapid growth of toys arrests as
households were quickly adopting TVs
disallow toys arrested directly
consumers with their lovable mascot
Jeffrey the giraffe they were so
successful but they completely
revolutionized industry and expanded it
very much
in 1978 the toy industry was only worth
500 million dollars but by 1990 it was
worth over 12 billion dollars after
height torres had 18,000 different toys
in 1450 locations around the world
they literally control a 25% of the toy
market and problem started right when
Charles Lazarus stepped down in 1994 the
new team started to cut back on the
variety of toys and she didn't want to
over saturate the market with the rise
of the e-commerce and changing toy taste
buzzers significant cutback on the
variety of toys and it wasn't just
Amazon it was also talking Walmart who
expand or twelve in their stores and
expanding their online presence as well
and this is why Toys R Us reduced their
offering they wanted to focus on
specific toys and undercut the
competitors and despite these efforts
Target and Walmart were able to offer
even bigger discount on their toys as
toys were not their main business while
we ran target don't need to profit on
their toys they don't even need to pop
it at all with toys they just need the
toys to get customers into the store and
buy other things from Worcester profit
on but for toys arrests their whole
store is toys so when they cut back the
price of the toys their whole revenue
decreases this was clearly not good in
Toys R Us knew it as well so they
completely change strategies they not
want to reduced a variety of toys
offerings but also stock to higher
prices see the whole goal with this was
that Target and Walmart would quickly
want out of stock with the toys as they
would heavily discounters Toys Toys R Us
was targeting the late holiday buyer who
was worried about ordering it online as
they thought that it might arrive late
but worked the last couple of years
consumer confidence in buying online has
significantly increased as they are more
used to buying online and this
absolutely destroyed their holiday sales
in fact they never even released their
holiday sales for 2017
you don't have to as they are a private
company but there have been continued a
tradition for several decades that just
show us how disappointing they probably
were toys-r-us lost customers by trying
to focus on cheaper prices instead the
experience that they were offering and
that people were used to and this means
so that there was nothing unique about
house arrest when compared to other
retailers the next biggest problem was a
lack of innovation in technology kids
nowadays are growing up with mobile
phones and computers and playing games
all day but toys the rest in responses
change in care to a new demographic they
added one more Islander store that had
technology but they didn't adapt to
technology they simply included it in
their stores now many people like to
claim that Toys R Us completely died
mainly due to Amazon and their lack of
online presence but this is actually not
the main reason but it is a relevant
reason they didn't keep up with the
generational shift of online consumerism
you have to remember that children are
not buying toys its parents that are
buying toys and the educator to what
parents want which is an online
experience with convenience and if
you're not going to do that then your
stores must stick out and there must be
a compelling reason for people to
actually come to physical stores but toy
service had just recently reduced a
variety after toys and we're trying to
compete in price brick-and-mortar stores
should not and cannot compete in price
it just simply have more expenses online
prices will always be cheaper but retail
stores should try to match prices the
prices don't have to be cheaper just
about the same or a little bit more as
fine as well price should not be the
reason that people come to your stores
it should be due to the experience when
people are coming to your stores for
cheaper prices
you're really not building any brand
loyalty they are only coming for the
cheaper prices but if they were going to
get into a car and come to your store
and buy the product that's pretty much
the same price as online now they're
coming for the experience and you're
building brand loyalty so it's not
of Amazon and the lack of their online
presence that killed them it's at Toys R
Us stores locked differentiation from
online retailers and there was no
incentive to come to physical stores
since being capital and other firms took
the company public in 2005 it had a huge
debt load when they were approaching
bankrupt in 2017 it upwards of five
billion dollars in liabilities and they
couldn't have chosen a worse time to
file for bankruptcy I mean they were
doing bad for a while but originally the
plan was just to downsize the stores
even after bankruptcy but by filing for
bankruptcy in September this completely
ruined their plans and I completely
ruined the 2017 holiday season I thought
then customers didn't know and even if
they did they'd really didn't care of
Toys R Us was doing bad it really did
affect them but what they filed for
bankruptcy it was all over the news and
everyone knew that Toys R Us was going
out of business and this really hurt
consumer confidence they didn't know if
they could buy toys in return it later
and they simply did not know what was
going to happen to towards arrests as a
result many people turned to other
stores for toys new 2017 holidays
seasons and just took a heavy toll on
Toys R Us maybe they could have gone
public a few years ago in order to raise
money and handle the debt or they could
have at least filed for bankruptcy after
the holiday season in January but you
really can't blame close arrest either
as it really was out of their control
but in the end is unfortunate timing for
Toys R Us to close all of their stores
in the u.s. overall Toys R Us failed
because they were moving away from what
made them special in the first place
which was their experience this was all
in an effort to undercut competitors
which in the first place wasn't that
successful and aided to your profit
margins which made it very tough to
handle their various large debt and
eventually that killed them instead they
should have kept Toys R Us a unique
experience getting people to come to
Toys R Us for the experience not for
cheaper toys and yes they could have
expanded their online presence which
would have helped them as well this is
why Toys R Us filled but will they be
able to come back all the toys RS
executive
are trying to reimburse with the new
brand in the holiday season is my 19 the
old executive toys arrest Richard Berry
is not a new Co the new company true
kids brand it's spelled t ru not t ru E
which is probably reminiscent of the
first letters of Toys R Us Richard told
the press but they were exploring
various options to try to come back from
freestanding stores to stores within
stores and he said that this time he
comes to play a central role in their
business in 2018 even after bankruptcy
Toys R Us was able to generate three
billion dollars in revenue based off of
that Richards claims that up to 40 to 50
percent of Toys R Us and market share
itself up for grabs Target and Walmart
or expanding their $20 but he thinks
it'll still be significant market share
left for them and he said at this time
they're really focusing on the
experience of the store making much
smaller stores with only 10,000 square
feet compared to the old Toys R Us
stores which are around 40,000 square
feet this is very ironic as Toys R Us
became a category killer I'm moving away
from these types of stores now initially
Toys R Us was a different experience in
itself but as for size this is ironic
they have been recently contacting toy
makers and apparently ever seems strong
support for this effort so it does seem
like they're making a reentry into your
market but well at work now at the
beginning there will be huge crowds that
come to your store as many porno static
about the company and want to see how it
changed but this really doesn't show
anything it's about how well they can
maintain these customers they need to
convince customers on this first visit
that is worth coming to their store for
their experience and clearly they are
trying to do this but we will only know
how effective this is when the stores
are actually open they need to match the
practice of online retailers and their
experience is what should drive people
to actually drive to your physical
stores and a good online presence would
obviously help as well and the thing is
in the past many other companies have
resurrected from the dead for example
Morris went bankrupt by around ten years
ago but now they're doing pretty well
Nintendo almost died with their clock
with you but they're really may I come
back with the Nintendo switch so it is
definitely possible for toys and rest to
come back but it will be an uphill
battle toys are rest used to be the
go-to place to get toys in the late
1900s and early 2000s but recently there
hasn't been any reason to go to toys
arrests as they don't offer anything
unique as a result traffic really slowed
down for towards arrests and this along
with her massive debt eventually killed
a company forcing them to file for
bankruptcy but there is hope
all executives have started a new brand
trying to bring back towards arrest and
they are trying to fix everything that
they messed up the first time around but
will these efforts actually pay out only
time will tell but that's all I have for
you guys on toys or less make sure to
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this beginner stuff a like and
consider subscribing if you like some
more videos just like this one
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one